We're going to put up on the screen
everything that you're involved in. Okay.
Look at this.
You executive produce 11
different properties for NBC.
Universal. Yes.
You have
two separate channels on Sirius XM,
including the aptly named radio A&E.
And you're about to release
your fifth kind of fifth book.
Someone said,
if you're not the architect
of our celebrity culture,
you're the ring
master of our celebrity culture.
Why do you think
everything you you do is so popular?
I think so.
Listen, I think the Housewives initially,
I owe a great deal of my success
to these women.
And this show,
which I think has replaced
the modern soap opera
in our TV landscape,
or is the modern soap
opera in our TV landscape.
And so that's
that's the place that I started.
And I think
that I've been able to connect
with my audience in a way
that's authentic
and that is a real dialog
and somehow keeps the conversation
keeps going. And I'm grateful for it.
All right.
You talk about the Housewives
and that is your biggest franchise.
I didn't realize that you have ten.
I know.
Ten all the way from New Jersey.
To Beverly Hills to Dubai.
And here's a taste
of some of the more viral moments. God.
So now you're going to show
all of the wine tossing and table.
Well, I do that.
That's what you're going to do.
Take a look. Okay, great. I love it.
I'm not talking to you.
And I'm just shut your mouth.
I know you raised.
Yes. How dare you?
Oh, dear me. Don't touch my husband.
She was saying, don't you.
Don't ever.
You don't for everybody to know.
You better
watch to talk about me or everybody.
You know,
after everyone even married my husband.
You know, in that
aspect.
Okay. I I got.
I got to tell folks,
while we're doing this,
Andy is looking at the app.
Does it go okay? Okay.
I mean, is that unwrap presented of
of Real Housewives?
It is a part of it.
Yes, I would say, listen,
what you're looking at
there was the climax of an entire season
of The Housewives show.
The boring part. Exactly.
So all I'm saying is, yes, that happened.
That was highly dramatic.
That was highly charged.
And when you get to that point,
then you have three episodes
of talking about what happened.
I mean, it's
all it's all
within the confines of the show.
But so yes, that happened.
What what do you want to say to
me about that, Chris?
Oh, talk about defense.
I have a little defense.
Well, yes, a couple of things.
Okay.
First of all,
is that for real
or are they just playing?
They're not playing.
It's for real.
We cast highly
dramatic women.
Look, are they aware
the cameras are there? Are they?
You know,
and I think that
the Beverly Hills
housewives of all of them
are the most aware
that they're on a television show
So but yes, of course,
they're aware that the cameras are there.
And but come to a reunion
taping sometime, Chris,
and you will see that this
they feel the way they feel.
They just happen to feel things
maybe stronger than than
your neighbor next door.
One of your books is titled Superficial,
which is not my opinion.
That's your title for another
book is a deep
a deep look at a shallow you. Yes.
Are you at all
embarrassed by what you do?
No, I'm really not,
because it makes so many people happy.
I go back to me being in Saint Louis
as a kid,
watching All My Children for years
and years and years.
And I loved All My Children.
It was just the great escape for me.
And I think that this show represents
that for a whole lot.
And I think it is
it can be really confrontational.
It can sometimes be
something that's a little
difficult to swallow.
But I think it's also about in the real
great moments,
it's about being a wife
and a mother and a sister and a friend
and a whole lot more.
So, yes, there's all that.
And then there's a whole lot more.
Jennifer Shah. Yes.
Who was a member of the Salt Lake City.
Yeah.
Real Housewives series
was just sentenced
to six and a half years in prison
for defrauding
thousands of victims
in a telemarketing scheme now.
You're on the record last November
as saying
that you hope she would get no jail time.
And the question I have is
why would you take her side
against the thousands of people
she defrauded,
including a lot of elderly?
I think I was hoping
that she was actually innocent.
I wouldn't have pleaded guilty.
That was before she pled guilty.
I mean, that I said that I would think
no, I think. Was I. Oh, really? Oh, God.
Anyway, now,
this is your easy to crack there.
Exactly.
Look, I think that I don't know
what the context of me saying that was,
but I think that the context was people
kept demanding of me
what is her status with the show?
And I'm like, it's up
for the it's up to the judge.
She's about to get sentenced, sentenced
to a lot of jail until the U.S.
gives him.
And she did something bad. Yes, she did.
And so she should go to jail.
I think I was saying, look, I you know,
sometimes you get to know someone
and you get to like them.
You hope
that they are not
guilty of something horrible.
Okay. Okay.
Yeah.
So then there's your show.
Watch what happens. Live.
Yes. Five nights a week.
You're going to come on as a guest.
Have you ever asked me that?
I'm asking you right now.
Well, I don't know.
Well, I.
I know you would.
I bet Dan Rather's been on several.
I understand the steam
journalists on all the time.
What do you think
is the appeal of that show?
I think it's authentic.
I think it's fun.
I think it takes late night
television and kind of turns
it inside out.
There's no pre-interview. There's
there.
It's just fun.
And it's spontaneous.
And, you know,
you never know what's going to happen.
One of
the things
that's the secret to success
is you get some great guests.
And I want to show a clip of you
with Meryl Streep.
Yes. Dustin Hoffman.
Yeah. Jack Nicholson.
Yeah. Robert Redford.
You marry one, you shag one,
you kill one.
Redford.
Marry maybe. Okay.
Yeah. Okay.
And
Jack Shag.
Okay.
And Dustin.
Ixnay, Dustin.
Okay. Very good.
First of all,
how big a deal to get somebody
like Meryl Streep on the show
and how big a deal that she played?
A lot.
I mean, I love what you said.
Yes, Jack. Yes.
Very big deal.
That was actually about
four years into our.
We're now 14 years into doing Watch
What Happens Live.
So that was early in our run.
And it was a huge turning point for us,
getting Meryl Streep to do the show.
It's a big deal.